we have received this statement from
downing street it reads we can confirm
the prime minister has received a
questionnaire from the metropolitan
police he will respond as required the
questionnaire is asking about what went
on in downing street in whitehall at the
height of the pandemic when strict
lockdown rules were in place
and we wait to see how the prime
minister responds you will remember that
we have learned in the last fortnight
that the metropolitan police itself an
organization now in crisis is
investigating 12 different events that
took place during different parts of the
lockdown uh during the coronavirus
pandemic in the belief that there might
have been breaches of coveted
regulations that were brought in by
boris johnson himself in order to slow
the spread of the virus we will we
learned from sue gray the senior
official in initially investigating all
of these different events uh that there
were about 16 different events
that were under consideration 12 of
which have ended up being investigated
by the police just for a sitting prime
minister to be probed in any way by the
police is potentially
hugely damaging to him and his prospects
for staying in office it was only
earlier today that a former conservative
leader ian duncan smith suggested that
if the police end up fining boris
johnson issuing a fixed penalty notice
saying that he breached his own lockdown
rules then it would be hard for him to
stay in office in duncan smith said in
the event of a penalty notice being
issued there would have to be a decision
made by my colleagues but i think it
would be very tough for anyone to remain
in office after that he didn't say he
would predict the future but he said it
was clearly not helpful if he was fined
it will be difficult he knows that ian
duncan smith reflects the view of many
many conservatives that i have spoken to
so even though we are talking tonight
against the backdrop of a possible
russian invasion on ukraine boris
johnson talking earlier this evening as
part of a conference call with joe biden
there are nevertheless very real
questions for the prime minister about
what will happen in this process that
could lead to the police issuing a fixed
penalty notice which he could choose to
accept or choose to fight but his party
is watching very closely and in the
event that the police find that they
have broke that he has broken lockdown
rules
the calculation around his future
changes at once